[Musik]
hathaway reich ranicki genau in der
reihenfolge der lifestyle israel gehabt
ihr der kanal kann echt ich dachte jetzt
alles übernommen
also herzlich willkommen zu unserer welt
heute backen wir einen richtig leckeren
und vor allem sehr einfachen kuchen mit
joghurt erdbeeren und rhabarber mögt ihr
kuchen jetzt ja sehr gut also starten
hat direkt ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten
wir verwenden dafür 100 gramm erdbeeren
300 gramm gestellten rabatt zehn gramm
zucker 30 gramm stärke und etwas vanille
extrakt drei eier die zimmer warm sind
175 gramm zucker salz etwas zitrone
abhebt jeweils 150 gramm naturjoghurt in
sonnenblumenöl 275 gramm mehl und
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver ja die
erdbeeren die habe ich bereits gewaschen
und geführte kamera du kannst du den
rhabarber schneiden können wir auch
schon geschält und zwar guck mal in
solche stücke also so ungefähr 1
zentimeter dicke scheiben ok und dann
einfach hier rein
ich mache mir den crime craft und machen
damit man sich nicht in die fingerkuppen
schneidet genau in dem man nicht drücken
von den schönen schneiden genau dass die
fingerspitzen ihnen liegen perfekt dann
schneit du mal weiter und er lernte
darfst die eier in die rückschlüsse
geben natürlich noch weiß drin
als rein
da ist noch drin
ja und das passt schon so das wird
nichts jetzt am besten tauschen wir
gleich bisschen die plätze
jetzt darfst du nicht reinpassen okay
die maschine ja nicht so rein gucken da
dürfen auch keine haare drüber okay
sonst verfängt sich dein förderin also
nicht reinpassen
auf ihrer tour weiter über ich nehme ich
mal
[Musik]
warum musste erst einmal gut aufpassen
jetzt schön verrühren genau
wenn es die eltern auch dazu machen
[Musik]
ich gebe ich meine größere schale
airline chefs dass man hier rein machen
okay da ist reiner und hier sollen ihre
vanille oder solle
[Musik]
okay wir machen einen teelöffel rainha
können sie mir noch mal einen teelöffel
[Musik]
weil es perfekt zu den erdbeeren passt
vanilla extrakt jetzt noch die stärke
jetzt dürft ihr hier verrühren habe ich
den deckel haben damit die stärke die
feuchtigkeit bindet von den erdbeeren
vom rhabarber und ich kann schon mal den
bug kriegen einschlagen hat den schon
eingestellt ab 26 zentimeter
ist ein austritt
ok quakenbrück
ok ich hab' das von euch gelernt dass
brauchen noch eine reibe hatte die hole
ich hier kurz mäuschen vorsichtig an
sich schmecken den rest machen jetzt so
weit wird damit ihr mithelfen könnte man
allerdings nicht mehr rühren das reicht
schon das obst kurz zur seite
jetzt bisschen zitronen abrief dazu den
probiere ich gerade aus kohle du darfst
öl rein schützen
bei mir hat den joghurt schön alles
auskratzen man auch das öl
wenn es button zur nebensache wird
passt schon kurz früheren ihr lernt das
echt toll bald muss die mama keinen
kuchen backen oder darf kein kuchen
backen es macht ihr dann immer noch da
bin ich jetzt aber schon traurig wartet
dann aber ein sieg über samuel das
kannst du zweifel
[Musik]
und dann darf samira das mehl mit
backpulver hier dazu sehen
das kann ich einfach so schütteln zack
zack zack und jetzt beim 7
und er nach höheren wertes wieder zur
ganz vorsichtig mit dem schneebesen
untergerührt ganz vorsichtig
ich finde in den teig gehört auch
nochmal extrakt oder noch ein bisschen
mit extrakten teig nicht recht jetzt
wird getuschelt
ich wünsche mir helfen wenn man
schneller macht dann geht mehr durch
weil es jetzt ganz schnell ab report
noch gar nicht gehört was aber auch
hören kann man das manchmal ganz ganz
einfach durch und jetzt haben wir alle
gerührt gern besser schmecken ja jetzt
sehr glücklich
die haut die sprüche raus die mainzer
als mutter sagt oder
ok während ihr zwar noch ab schlägt kann
ich schon einen teig einfüllen
jetzt will ich den teig hier einfach ein
als ihr seht ist ein superschneller
kuchen sogar mit kindern schnell
gebacken
ok hier kommen jetzt noch tier abba und
erbstücke drauf und dann kann der kuchen
gebacken werden und wir können die küche
aufräumen yeah wir haben die küche auf
[Gelächter]
entschuldigung aber auch zusammen
gebacken
wenn ich mit euch zusammen spiele dann
räume ich auch mit euch die spielsachen
[Musik]
was ist nur warum kennst du die in
minecraft kanal kann man dich abonnieren
echt wie fehler wie viele jobs
verschuldung schon okay ich bleib beim
backen
der kuchen kommt jetzt in den backofen
auf sagt ella trinkt es richtig dass
ausgaben so die stärke mit dem rhabarber
mit der erdbeere schmeckt das hier ist
ja gut schalten schnell für das kind da
wird nichts verschwendet man könnte
meinen der krieg nur vor der kamera was
zu essen so hinter der kamera seele
kocht nie zu hause
sally backe kuchen tarife wegberg wie du
er lag die mama oma packt die man auch
ohne kamera für euch kauft ja auch für
euch ja geht's dir gut hier im haushalt
krieg später geld dafür zwei mäusen okay
ich kann auch ohne euch aufräumen haben
heute ich rufe euch wenn der kuchen
fertig ist okay okay lass gehört ich ruf
dich wenn der kuchen fertig ist
alle fragen sich jetzt was heckt sie
jetzt schon wieder aus
ich sag doch das ist nur als kind so ein
bisschen aber jetzt kann ich gut ok
vinyl extrakt liebhaber so lieske
[Musik]
16 uhr in waghäusel
die kinder sind gerade im garten der
kuren ist abgekühlt
kelly osbourne hat den kuchen mit einem
back baumäste baum gelöst danach hat sie
durch eine elegante handbewegung das
backpapier unter dem kuchen weggezogen
um den kuchen auf den torten teller zu
transportieren
der kuchen ist komplett abgekühlt wurde
mit süßem schnee bestreut und
angeschnitten
jetzt kommt gleich sarah sarah p punkt
wie kann ich den kuchen probieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich war vor dem rhythmus nächstes waren
bei der geburt probieren
probier den kuchen jetzt das mikrofon
unterstützt unsere serie sehr wichtig
für uns ist
hab ich aus unserem lied entnommen
[Gelächter]
mit süß und säuerlich zitronen abrieb
und joghurt und joghurt sehr lecker
lecker wie chronisch geworden so könnte
eine bauchbinde machen
sally und sarah wir sind bald auf tour
die 14 und 15 jahre alt ich bin auch
schon 15 kanal möchte dir dass wir einen
singstar kanal machen dann kommentiert
wie oft gehen auf tour ok wird mir
schmeckt lecker säuerliche ein süßes mit
lösung schnee drauf schon schöner
sonntagskuchen gehen wir mal einfach
schnell machen kann
den hatte ich neulich übrigens auch in
einem live video gemacht ja also mich
kinder mit kinder zehn minuten
zubereitungszeit ohne kinder
5 zum glück habe ich keine kinder
dann geht es bei mir nur stunden ich
habe eine katze die schönste kann man
kurz und welt von katharina einblenden
ich habe herr kuki wir werden jetzt im
anschluss die bilder von sarahs wenn die
1 nach 20 minuten
wir ziehen das video und eine weitere
halbe stunde ohne werbepause die
folgenden sendungen können sich um eine
stunde verschieben
also packt den kuchen gerne nach
probiert ihn aus kostet ihn markiert
mich auf eure fotos da kommentiere ich
auch regelmäßig und schaue mir eure
bilder an und jetzt viel spaß mit der
diashow bis zum nächsten mal
diashow die glauben jetzt wir machen uns
nicht aber wir machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]